so I think the new plan is is very
welcomed it does give us a light at the
end of the tunnel that over the the next
35 10 15 years we will hopefully have
the amount of staff in the NHS both
medical nursing Allied health
professionals that we really need to be
able to provide the care that we would
all want to provide for our population
so I think it is hugely welcomed but I
think it is really important that we
recognize that this is a long-term fix
and it doesn't solve the problems that
we have here and now in the present time
where we have a huge demand on the NHS
both from the backlog and from emergency
care and and we have a staff who have
been through a lot over the last three
four years and and they are stretched we
recognize that you know our staff are
putting in a huge amount of effort and
being able to value our staff to be able
to retain them to be able to offer over
and above what we can just purely in
financial terms it's critical if we want
to retain this staff within the within
the trust yeah how do you retain them I
mean some of the things that are
mentioned in this plan better flexible
working better Career Development Better
Health and well-being and pension scheme
reform as well and there was something
mentioned as well about recently retired
consultant doctors offering their
availability to trusts will that help so
I think all of these factors help in
terms of trying to retain some of our
most valued
um you know colleagues and staff who
work in the organizations some of those
are National initiatives but there are a
number of local initiatives and you
mentioned yourselves around how we
attract um some doctors and nursing
through the fellowship programs and as
well as providing high quality training
for them what is critical is that we
provide that pastoral element is around
supporting them if they're coming to a
new country it's about the aspects of
life outside of work social Financial
cultural aspects Faith aspects are
really important so Staff feel valued
it's is it's really simple we need to
value our staff we need to make them
feel as a valuable members of the of the
community members of the organization
and with that hopefully we will retain
as many staff as possible but we do
recognize that this is a very very
difficult time there are a number of
vacancies in the NHS and people have got
offers in a whole range of different
professions so we need to work extra
hard for people to come and work within
the NHS and people don't come to the NHS
to make lots of money they come here to
look after patients they come here to to
care for our populations and we need to
give them that time support to be able
to allow them to do that because
if we do that it becomes a very
rewarding profession to work in and can
you truly fix NHS England without having
a similar social care plan in place so I
think we've seen over the last few years
how critical that partnership working
with our social care and partners and
colleagues is it absolutely has to be
part and parcel of how we fix the NHS if
we ever can fix the NHS but to our own
to to be able to make sure that that our
patients and population get the right
care in the right place that has to be a
combined effort between you know what we
do within acute Healthcare but also what
happens in Primary Care Community Care
and in Social care all of these aspects
are so interdependent it's critical to
get it right and
saying that you felt you felt well was
it was challenging what what are the
pressures at the moment on your hospital
and because I know your vacancy rates
are low but you'll be you'll be
struggling like all hospitals won't you
with waiting times whether it be for
ambulances or care
yeah so I mean across the whole adhs
everybody is very acutely aware of the
backlog of patients that we absolutely
want to treat we don't want anybody
waiting longer for treatment than they
would expect to we don't want anybody
coming to harm for having to wait too
long and that creates pressure because
you know as health professionals we want
to provide that care in a timely way and
having those backlogs creates an innate
pressure within us as well as the
pressure of you know reaching certain
targets we all want to meet those
targets so that patients get treated in
a timely way but that does cause
pressure on staff who are already in a
very sort of stretched position and
similarly an urgent in emergency care
you know we've had to make significant
Investments so that the quality of care
and the timeliness of that care that we
provide it meets the expectations of of
the people who are coming to this
hospital so that we can get ambulances
back on the road in time and and we have
to recognize that we do need those
additional staff and those additional
Investments if we want to provide that
quality of care